how do you integrate
deep work into your life what are
different scheduling strategies
that you would recommend just at a high
level yeah what are different ideas
there
well i mean i'm a big fan of time
blocking right so
if you're facing your workday don't
allow
like your inbox or a to-do list to sort
of drive you don't just come into your
day and think what do i want to do next
yes i mean i'm a big plan of saying
here's the time here's the time
available
let me make a plan for it all right so i
have a meeting here of an appointment
here here's what's left what do i
actually want to do with it so
in this half hour i'm going to work on
this for this 90 minute block i'm going
to work on that and during this hour i'm
going to try to fit this in and then
actually have this half hour gap between
two meetings so why don't i take
advantage of that to go run five errands
i can kind of batch those together
but blocking out in advance this is what
i want to do with the time available
i mean i find that's much more effective
now once you're doing this once you're
in a discipline of time blocking
it's much easier to actually see this is
where i want for example the deep work
and i can get a handle on the other
things that need to happen and find
better places to
fit them so i can prioritize this and
you're going to get a lot more of that
done
than if it's just going through your day
and saying what's next i schedule every
single day
kind of thing so as i could try to in
the morning to try to uh
have a plan yeah so you know i do a
quarterly weekly daily planning
so at the semester or quarterly level i
have a big picture
vision for what i'm trying to get done
you know during the fall let's say or
during the winter
like i want to these are there's a
deadline coming up for academic papers
at the end of the season here's what i'm
working on
i want to have this many chapters done
of a book something like this like you
have the
the big picture vision of what you want
to get done then weekly
you look at that and then you look at
your week and you put together a plan
for like okay what am i going to
what's my week going to look like what
do i need to do how am i going to make
progress on these things maybe
maybe i need to do an hour every morning
or i see that monday is my only really
empty day so that's going to be the day
that i really need to nail on writing or
something like this
and then every day you look at your
weekly plan
and say only block off the actual hours
so you do that that three scales the
the quarterly down the weekly down to
daily and we're talking about
actual times of day versus so the
alternative is
what i end up doing a lot i'm not sure
it's the best way to do it
is uh uh scheduling
the duration of time this is this is
called the luxury when you don't have
any meetings i'm like
religiously don't do meetings
all other academics are jealous of you
by the way yeah i know
no zoo meetings uh i i find those
are that's one of the worst tragedies
tragedies of the pandemic
it's both the opportunity to what okay
the positive thing
is to have more time with your family
you know sort of reconnect in many ways
and
that that's really interesting uh be
able to
remotely sort of not waste time on
travel and all those kinds of things the
negative
is actually both those things are also
sources of the negative
uh but the negative is like it seems
like people have multiplied the number
of meetings because they're so easy to
schedule
and there's nothing more draining
to me intellectually philosophically
just my spirit is destroyed
by even a 10-minute zoom meeting like
what are we doing here
what's the meaning of life i have
every zoo meeting is i have an
existential crisis so kierkegaard with a
internet connection uh
so uh what the hell were we talking
about oh
so when you don't have meetings there's
a luxury to really
allow for certain things if they need to
like the important things
like deep work sessions to last way
longer than
you uh maybe planned for i mean that's
my goal is to try to schedule
the goal is to schedule to sit and focus
for a particular task for an hour
and hope i can keep going yeah and i
hope i can get lost in it
and uh do you find that this
is at all an okay way to go
and uh the time blocking is just
something you have to do
to actually be an adult and operate in
this real world
or is there some magic to the time
blocking
well i mean there's magic to the
intention
there's magic to it if you have varied
responsibilities right so
i'm often juggling multiple jobs
essentially there's
there's academic stuff there's teaching
stuff there's book stuff there's the
the business surrounding you know
surrounding my my book stuff
but i'm of your same mindset if a deep
work session is going
well just rock and roll and let it let
it go on so like one of the big keys of
time block at least the way i do it so i
even you know sell this
planner to help people time block it has
many columns because the discipline is
oh if your
initial schedule changes you just move
over one next time you get a chance to
move over one column
and then you just fix it for the time
that's remaining so in other words
there's not
there's no bonus for i made a schedule
and i stuck with it
like there's actually just like you get
a prize for it right like for me the
prize is i have an intentional plan for
my time
and if i have to change that plan that's
fine like the state i want to be is
basically at any point in the day i've
thought about what time remains and
and gave it some thought for what to do
because i'll do the same thing even
though i have a lot more
meetings and other types of things i
have to do my various jobs and
i basically prioritize the deep work and
they get yelled at a lot
so that's kind of my strategy is like
just be okay just be okay getting yelled
at a lot because i feel you if you're
rolling
yeah well that's that's what it is for
me like with writing i think it's
writing so hard in a certain way that
it's you don't really get on a roll in
some sense like it's just difficult
uh but working on proofs it's very
hard to pull yourself away from a proof
if you start to get some traction just
you've been at it for a couple hours
then you feel the uh
the pins and tumblers starting to click
together and progress is being made
it's really hard to call pull away from
that so so i'm willing to get yelled at
by almost everyone
of course there is also uh a positive
effect to
uh pulling yourself out of it when
things are going great because then
you're kind of excited to resume
yeah as opposed to stopping on a on a
dead end that's true
that there's a the yeah there's a
uh there's an extra force of
procrastination that comes with if you
stop on a dead end
to return to the task yeah or or a cold
start
yeah whenever i feel like i'm in a stage
now i submitted a few papers recently
so now we're sort of starting something
up from cold
and it it takes way too long to get
going because it's very hard to
it's very hard to get the motivation to
schedule a time when it's not yeah we're
in it like
here's where we are we feel like
something's about to give here we need
the very early stages where it's just
i don't know i'm going to read hard
papers and it's going to be hard to
understand them i'm going to have no
idea how to make progress
it's not it's not motivating
you